[MUSIC PLAYING]
TERRY PATTEN: Hi, everybody.
I'm excited to be here,
particularly in the citadel,
Google, because I think
the broad cultural force
that intelligent,
rational, technologically
sophisticated, scientifically
innovative players are
able to bring to our
world is so crucial
and right now, so
under utilized.
I think we have a
huge opportunity.
You have a huge
opportunity, and frankly,
as you'll hear a responsibility.
And I'll be talking about
how the challenges are not
really just problems
to be figured out,
but they're an
existential challenge
to our whole way of being human
and to our self understanding
and our orientation.
I'll get into that.
Mainly, I want to talk
about three things.
One of them is this
idea of a meta-crisis.
Very often, we talk
about global warming.
And perhaps, in
some conversations
we have a broader
view, and we talk
about the larger ecological
emergency, which isn't
reducible to global warming.
The destruction of so much of
the rainforest, for instance,
shrinking the
lungs of the planet
is not exactly the
same as global warming,
and this broader
ecological predicament
is a lot more severe
than people realize.
It's part of what
I want to express.
On the other hand, when
people have the courage
to face directly the
actual nature of our moment
and how dire it is in some ways.
It tends to bring about
an orientation of despair.
There's a huge community
that's grown up, for example,
around the idea of
civilizational collapse,
the idea that it is
inevitable that we
will see societal collapse
relatively near term.
I disagree with that,
and I'll be explaining
why that's not only
logically flawed, but morally
reprehensible.
And that's an important piece
of what I want to share.
However, what it boils
down to is an opportunity
and a challenge for
us each individually.
I often use the
metaphor of a zen koan.
This meta-crisis is an
impossible question.
Like in zen, the
monk is sometimes
given an impossible
question, like what
is the sound of
one hand clapping,
or show me your original
face, the one you had
before your parents were born.
And those questions
stop the mind,
and they and they
require the aspirant
to go beyond their
whole way of being.
It's a challenge that's
non-linear you can't figure out
the answer to a koan.
You have to dwell in the
tensions that the koan creates.
I think this crisis
represents that kind
of a transformational
pressure cooker
that admittedly, most of
humanity is busy ignoring
and not looking at.
We live in a culture
pretty profoundly dedicated
to a kind of radical denialism.
On the other hand, though, we
live in this time for a reason.
It is an opportunity.
And ultimately, I find it
thrilling and inspiring.
And I hope by the
end of this talk,
you'll be feeling the same way.
The second thing I
want to talk about
is a deeper dive into what
time it is on the planet
and what that means for us, the
nature of this tipping point,
as an existential matter.
And then finally, I
want to talk to you
about what the innovators--
and here at Google,
it's like a citadel
of what I call the innovators,
the unique role that innovators
will play or fail
to play at a very
crucial moment in the whole
evolutionary trajectory
of this human experiment.
Now, this is a little bit
of a different kind of talk
than you've probably
heard before.
You might think of it
as a meta synthesis.
A synthesis might bring together
a lot of data and insights
and factoids of a
variety of kinds
to deliver a shift of view.
That's what a synthesis is.
But if you really want
to comprehend what's
going on right now, it
requires a whole series
of such syntheses.
And so what I'm going
to be delivering
is a meta synthesis
that therefore will not
be peppered with all
kinds of references
to particular studies or to
facts you haven't heard before.
It's going to really have to
do with an invitation for you
to make your way of seeing
an object of your attention
to make your way of being an
object of your inspection,
and to draw you
much more profoundly
into an opportunity
for new possibility.
So I invite you to suspend your
usual way of listening in order
to be available to
making real use,
downloading this meta synthesis
that I'll be offering.
Another thing that is
important to set out,
just as a vocabulary
for us to use
is the idea of
world views, which
we've all heard of, that people
occupy certain world views.
And we generally talk
about the differing world
views, for instance, of
Republicans and Democrats
in the United
States, or we might
talk about the world views of
people in an African country,
or diverse, indigenous
world views, et cetera.
But it's important
to understand just
how profound and far
reaching that idea
is, that in a sense, when we
occupy a certain way of seeing
reality, all kinds of
implicit assumptions
are part and parcel
of our world view,
and just that we can
recognize world views and even
observe some things
about our own world view
doesn't deliver us from the
limiting function of world
views.
A world view is a
total perspective.
It has implicit in it values.
It has implicit in it attitudes.
It has implicit in it ways
of relating to other people.
And most of that tends to
be invisible to the occupant
of any world view.
And so as we begin to talk
here about how our crisis is
operating, we have to look at
how the conflict of world views
plays.
And I'll go into this a
bit more as we apply it.
Where are we right now?
Well, I think that among
democratic voters, recently,
a poll identified climate
change, which is really
the proxy for all
ecological issues,
as I think, the fifth most
urgent issue in the minds
of democratic voters.
But in the last year, if
you've been paying attention,
you've probably seen
a new IPCC report
that outlines just
how devastating 1.5
centigrade rays of global
temperatures would be.
You've also seen a
US climate report
that underlines those findings.
You've maybe seen
the new findings
that show that ocean warming
has been taking place way more
rapidly than anyone
had previously
been projecting, by somewhere
between 40% and 60%.
You may have--
well, I won't keep--
this is a litany.
We hear it all the time.
You don't really need
that education from me.
What you are aware of is
that we're not addressing it,
and that the struggle to begin
to address it effectively
is, if you've paid attention,
even to European politics,
where the countries
there are really
our leaders in the
world, it's not
as if the level of
awareness and action
that the European
countries are taking
is adequate to the
problem at all.
And here in the United
States, nothing is happening.
So the crisis, even
if we think about it
in climate or ecological
terms, and the meta-crisis
is much more than that, still
hinges on cultural changes
and cultural communication.
And all kinds of
factors are interacting.
You get serious about
climate, pretty soon,
you're really interested
in campaign finance reform.
Then you're interested
in reforming
the Balkanization of media.
Then you're interested
in voting rights.
I mean, you bounce around from
issue to issue as an activist,
because everything is entangled.
We have an entangled
series of crises.
If you've looked
closely at what's
happening in the
educational system,
not just in the United
States, but around the world,
you discover, wow, our whole
way of educating ourselves
and younger people
is in a crisis.
The health care system
in the United States
is particularly in crisis.
We also can see that there are
crises that are psychological,
addiction, depression,
anxiety, breakdown of family,
and the interaction of family
breakdown and neighborhood,
community breakdown.
We can talk about this
crisis from multiple angles.
But really, there's
only one world.
And no matter what lens we put
on, no matter what analytics we
focus our attention on,
we're catching a partial view
of a larger phenomenon.
And it's a single phenomenon.
We may be thinking of it
as an ecological crisis.
We may be thinking of it as
a psychological or spiritual
crisis.
We may be thinking of
it as a cultural crisis
and a breakdown of
community, family, et cetera.
We may be thinking of it
as a crisis of government
and economics and finance.
And it is all of these things.
But it's not reducible
to any one of them.
That's why it's a meta-crisis.
And in a way, crisis isn't
quite the right word.
It's really kind
of a predicament.
The ecological analysis
that is simplest and easiest
to communicate,
argues, essentially,
that we have gone for
some years into overshoot.
I think it's summarized
the best by a book called
"Overshoot" by William Catton
that was published 30 years ago
almost.
And it basically
identifies a way
of understanding any
ecosystem, whether you're
talking about an
island or a pond
or a Petri dish or a planet.
And whatever ecosystem
you're describing,
whatever environment, it has
a certain carrying capacity.
And its carrying
capacity is the quantity
of any particular animal or
plant, any life form that
can be sustainably supported
in that ecosystem over time,
permanently.
And when you exceed the carrying
capacity of that ecosystem,
you might successfully
continue for a while
by drawing down certain
resources temporarily.
The problem is that those
resources you draw down then
are in shorter
supply, and you may
have reduced the
ultimate carrying
capacity of that ecosystem.
You've drawn down
non-renewable resources,
or you've damaged the systems
through which resources
can regenerate.
And Catton's
historical analysis is
that in an accident of
historical sequence,
around 1,500 Europeans
discovered the New World,
and very quickly were able to
draw huge amounts of resources
from the New World.
So the European
Western countries
went through a period of
rapid economic expansion,
based on the availability of
unlimited resources, which
he calls the corner
cornucopian myth.
The idea is that there
are now and will always
be unlimited resources.
And that was proven
out, because very soon
after the discovery
of the New World,
and the full exploitation of
the incredible rise of wealth
that that brought, there
was the discovery of coal
and then the discovery
of oil and then
the discovery of natural gas
and the exploitation of all
the fossil fuels.
So we have gone through a
process in now world culture,
because those European countries
that originally discovered
the world view,
it is their legacy
that is now the pattern
of the whole modern world.
No matter what part of
the world you go to,
the systems that
are dominant are
the legacy of that original--
the conquest of the world
by the white man's tribes,
we might call it.
So that world has now
instantiated a presumption
of unlimited resources and
never ending economic expansion,
and we're now in the
neighborhood of a peak oil
moment, in which the efficiency
with which we can make use
of the remaining fossil
fuels is degrading,
and that's periodically
sending shocks.
It's one of the reasons that our
financial markets are so jumpy,
why there is so much pessimism,
why so many people say
that things are on
the wrong track,
et cetera, et cetera. this sense
of disquiet, this sense that we
are headed for some kind
of apocalyptic calamity
is sort of in the water system.
You go to the multiplex.
Three out of four movies
are about saving the world.
Well, we wouldn't be saving
the world if it weren't that we
believed in some way that
something about what we rest in
is endangered.
So there's a deep
malaise and a confusion
that is culturally
pervasive that partly comes
from this intuition
of this situation
that the cornucopian era
is now under challenge.
I personally believe
that we will discover
a relatively free,
relatively clean energy
source at some
point, and that there
will be another round of
cornucopian possibility.
But the unsustainability
of a long term cornucopian
orientation needs to be--
well, the sustainability
of it needs to be examined.
The presumption that we
can simply take for granted
that this orientation will
be a permanent condition
of our existence deserves
critical inspection.
Let me digress for a moment
and introduce a vocabulary.
I called you guys
innovators, and I
was drawing on a very
simple categorization
that I make of what I
consider the three most
important conversations
that human beings are
having at this time.
We are at a time in which we are
reaching an inflection point,
and we are beginning to have
serious conversations in which
our very best intelligence
is in dialogue with itself
in the form of the most
intelligent participants.
But we're having three different
conversations that I think,
each of which I
believe are essential.
And those conversations are not
in dialogue with one another.
So one of them I
call the innovators.
And I very frequently
mentioned Larry Page as one
of the leading thinkers of
that innovator conversation,
along with many, many,
many others, too many
to mention adequately.
But I'll throw out a few
names, but the obvious people,
Elon Musk, Bill Gates.
But Sam Harris-- you know,
they're not all entrepreneurs,
necessarily.
Rational-- Steven
Pinker, a variety
of innovators who are in
the most powerful position
right now and are seen
broadly in our culture
as the people who are
creating the future.
Because not only are they
capturing the flag in terms
of technological and
scientific advances,
they're capturing
the flag in terms
of the entrepreneurial
deployment of those advances,
and therefore, they have
the cultural influence
and the money to really
back up their intention
to be the change, map the
future of possibility.
But I kind of briefly
alluded to this point of view
that I describe and give
the simple name ecologists.
And I would say the
ecologists ascribe
to the narrative I offered,
that the cornucopian myth is
a myth, that the
Malthusian attitude,
which is that we are
headed for a collision--
you know, the
Malthusians have been
proven wrong again and
again and again and again
throughout history.
So the evidence
kind of stacks up
to support a
cornucopian orientation,
except we're dealing
with a collision
of a different character
than we ever have before.
And we don't see solutions.
I'll get into that in a minute.
So I think that
ecologists, you know,
there's a great range of
people I would call ecologists
I would include
my friend, Michael
Dowd, the evolutionary
evangelist, who's
a very rational character.
But I would also include--
for instance, there's a
non-profit organization
here in San Francisco called
the Pachamama Alliance, where
a financier, Bill Twist
and his wife Lynne,
who was the kind of
leader of the Hunger
Project for many years, had
a visit to Achuar people
in the Amazon and
Ecuador and formed
an alliance with
indigenous people,
and they're bringing services
into that part of the world
and trying to preserve
chunks of the forest,
the habitat of those people.
But what they're arguing
for, more fundamentally,
is that there is a kind of--
we have lost our memory of how
to live on this planet in a way
that doesn't destroy it,
and that there is something
fundamental in the existential
orientation of a life that
knows at a deep unconscious
or pre-conscious level
that it is killing its host,
that all of us are sick,
it would be argued, because
how we feed ourselves,
how we transport ourselves,
how we earn our living,
and everything else are
intertwined inexorably
with a larger system that
is completely unsustainable.
And it's producing horrific
effects that offend us,
morally and spiritually.
And the ecologists are
arguing in a variety
of ways-- some of
them simply have
to do with a rational
argument about how
to preserve our future.
Others have to do with the
whole field of eco psychology
as one of the expressions of
this ecological point of view.
And there are very intelligent,
very well-read, very deeply--
I'm going to be
offering you a link
to a rather terrifying,
but very well researched
paper called "Deep Adaptation"
by an academic ecologist,
somebody in the field
of sustainability.
It's kind of business
management for sustainability
is now a pretty big field, and
he's a leading expert there.
And he's arguing for this
scenario of societal collapse.
Now, there's a
third group that I
think is equally important
that I call the evolutionaries.
And I would number myself
as an evolutionary.
What characterizes
evolutionaries is,
is that we recognize evolution
as a multidimensional affair.
It wasn't just
biological evolution,
which is what people
usually think of,
the adaptive emergence
of new traits.
There was cosmic evolution
before the earth was formed
and in the early years of the
earth, that just took place
in the [INAUDIBLE]
sphere, before it
moved into the biosphere
and created the biosphere.
And really, the most
important evolution
that's been going on
for the last 500 years
has been cultural
evolution, the evolution
in the noetic sphere,
the interiors,
the collective learning
of human beings.
And it's here that we
have our biggest problem,
because no matter how
much we might locate
our crisis as a
matter of maintaining
a habitable earth, our ability
to reach agreements and make
intelligent,
collective decisions is
crucial to any solution we
might want to instantiate.
And we can all see how broken--
we say our politics
are broken, but it's
a much more pervasive matter.
So evolutionaries are those
who take a meta perspective
on the perspectives
in play and recognize
that we are only
effective if we can
put on the lens of the person
we're in discourse with,
and if we can draw ourselves
beyond the limits of the world
view we're inhabiting, and
that to do that, we need
a lot of things that
radically reformat
the hard drive, for example,
higher states of consciousness.
Particularly, there
are different species
of those higher states that we
can visit through entheogens
or psychedelics, or that
we can intentionally
cultivate through
practice of meditation,
a variety of approaches.
That's only one part of what
evolutionaries bring in.
Part of what evolutionaries
are able to see
is the way that world views
define everything we can see.
So evolutionaries are
looking at this whole matter
in an evolutionary context
and are recognizing
its evolutionary implications.
And there's a lot more
to say about that,
but very briefly, we
are alive at a time when
from an evolutionary
perspective of life on Earth,
of not just the human species,
but most even marginally
intelligent species, not all,
but most mammalian species,
there's an existential
crisis brewing right now.
What happens in your lifetimes
will have profound implications
to the future, not
just of human life,
but of every charismatic
megafauna species
that you might care about.
And we are here.
Who is going to be a part of
the creation of that future?
And who has an opportunity
to make a moral difference?
We are the ones.
When we take that seriously,
it tends to sober us a lot.
This particular moment in
time, I think maybe some of you
have noticed the 11
year time frame that
was identified in
the most recent IPCC
report about 1.5 degrees
centigrade temperature
increase.
We have to make radical
changes that transform
our whole pattern of
our whole economy,
relative to what powers
us, fossil fuels,
and accomplish it in
something like 11 years,
according to that
particular analysis.
Now, is that analysis
absolutely dependable?
Every analysis and every
perspective, by the way,
is both true and partial.
I think what we can know and how
well we can know it needs to be
viewed with a kind of
self-critical awareness,
that that 11 year--
at the end, nobody
knows for sure.
But really, well-informed,
intelligent, deep people
have done their best to quantify
our window of opportunity.
And they've come
up with 11 years.
That's enough for me.
What I have decided,
and what I offer
to you is the idea
that as much as you
may look at things through
a certain world view,
and as much as that may
be inescapable, that is,
you can't just notice that
there are multiple world views
and escape the
limits of your own.
You are bound to it, but
you can be in conversation
with perspectives
that are only apparent
from outside your world view.
It is a little like state
specific memory, you know--
I remember, as a
kid seeing kind of--
I don't think it was
a Hitchcock movie,
but sort of a similar
to a Hitchcock
movie, about a
guy who could only
remember certain things when
he was drunk or sometimes
in a rage, or whatever.
Only in a certain state are
certain things perceptible.
Well, we can think about some of
what we're dealing with, using
that as a useful metaphor.
It illuminates the fact
that we are actually
occupying entirely
different realities,
and yet, we talk
with one another
in a single body
of discourse, as
if there were a single
knowable truth that we all
ought to be able to
talk one another into.
Well, this orientation that
we have a definable problem
that we can figure out, and that
has a single definable solution
is completely obsolete.
We are facing in
this meta-crisis
a necessity of transformation
on every level of human life.
It's what I refer to in my
book as whole systems change.
That means that there are
psychological changes, what
our idea is of a successful life
well-lived, what our ideas are
about satisfying relationships,
what we aspire to,
what gives our life meaning
and purpose, the ways that we
enjoy.
All that's going to have
to go through a morph.
It does arrive on
a personal level.
Maybe we begin by thinking of
this as an engineering problem,
of coming up with a relatively
free and cheap energy
source that will liberate
us from this problem,
but that wouldn't suffice.
In fact, there are
analyses of what
we're facing that
don't focus even
on ecology, that regard the
whole matter as a matter
of a self-accelerating pattern.
Maybe some of you are aware
of a very important book that
was published in 2017 by the
physicist Geoffrey West, who
is the director of the
Santa Fe Institute.
The title of the
book is "Scale,"
and in it, he used the tools
of physics, mainly math
and ratios, to analyze
biological and social systems.
And he came up with a lot
of very interesting insights
about metabolism and lifespan
and cities and so forth.
But to me, the most
interesting single piece
of that broad analysis
was his tracking
historically of the
major transformations
of the techno economic
means of production
that power human societies, like
the discovery and use of stone
tools, or agriculture.
He marked each one that
had an advent of out
of a major increase,
because it definitely
precedes in the stage process.
It isn't a smooth
ramped trajectory.
And what he noticed was
that each transformation
happened faster and faster
and faster and faster.
And he noted, gosh, if we
are all together involved
in a self-accelerating pattern,
we have a design problem,
because a self-accelerating
pattern is self-terminating.
You can't go faster
and faster forever.
If you track changes
on a timeline,
and at first, they're
very slow, and then
they're a little faster and
faster and faster and faster
and faster and faster, you
come upon a time singularity.
And he identified as a
result of that analysis
that a grand unified
theory of sustainability
was the way he put it that
combined our understandings
of economics and politics
and social theory and all
the hard sciences
would be necessary
in order to turn that around.
He imagined that one of
these stage transitions
might give us the
breathing space
to make that kind
of a radical turn
toward a permanently sustainable
presence on the planet.
But it was really something
he conceived of abstractly
as a hypothetical.
Another futurist, Peter Russell,
came to the same conclusions,
examining entirely
different data.
But in a way, it's an
extension of the thesis
that Alvin Toffler put
forward almost 30 years ago
in "Future Shock."
And part of our meta-crisis is
simply the human adaptation.
We talk a lot about how much our
lives have changed because we
live so much of it online, and
our relationships are mediated,
and that's affecting us
in both good and bad ways,
and it's very different
now to be 10 or 15 or 20.
Everybody is going through a
transformation because of that,
and that's a piece
of our meta-crisis.
The argument there is
that change is stressful,
and complexification
is stressful,
and this self-accelerated
crisis is speeding up
change and complexification
to a point that it's
beginning to test the
neurological limits
of human adaptation.
So that may be true.
It's important to
realize, though,
that when we look at all of
these critical tipping points,
I've been mentioning, primarily,
depressing, negative ones.
But there are equally inspiring,
potentially positive ones
in play, not just
technologically,
but you know, for instance,
all the wisdom traditions
of every culture on Earth
have been in conversation now
in at least a beginning way
for over 50, maybe 75 years.
And we now have a couple of
generations of Westerners,
who've applied themselves to
the technologies of awakening
or enlightenment that
come from the East.
And those people
are in conversation
with each other informed
by the beneficial influence
of scientific
analytical tools, I
mean, just comparative
religion, for example.
But much more
rigorous than that,
we're quantifying
all kinds of things,
and our development
of the technology
of becoming our best, not
just consciousness hacking,
but peak performance
as a general category,
is reaching a whole new level
of objective clarification.
And we have a lot of
people who are applying
those tools, and
who are achieving
different levels of
clarity and excellence,
who are advancing the
dialogue, just as in AI, we
may get to a point where
intelligent machines can
redesign even more
intelligent machines.
We already have people
who are embodying
excellence, who are refining the
field of embodying excellence.
And there's the beginnings
of the virtuous cycle
that might bring about
a positive singularity
of that kind.
And there are other dynamics
that are very important.
One of the things that I get
into in my book pretty richly
is our disasters are going to
open windows of opportunity
for more fundamental
systems redesign,
that after it's too late
will be when it becomes
possible to do many things.
One of the problems that we
have with the current dialog
is that everybody participating
in it, for the most part, very
few, few
evolutionaries, are free
enough from the implications
not to be so gripped by the fear
and grief that come upon
us when we contemplate
civilizational collapse, or the
end of the human experiment,
that they're able to have enough
free attention to participate
with all their capacities.
And so a big subsection
of what I teach
and what I bring to
people is an understanding
that no matter
what, you are going
to, at some point in your
life, experience what
the Buddhists call the
heavenly messenger, sickness,
old age, and death.
You will, and we all
will experience loss.
We will all experience pain.
And we'll eventually
cease to exist.
And that's always
been OK with us.
So the fact that we're
facing some of this
collectively, that the most
extreme challenges in every one
of our individual
lives, are challenges
that we face together,
this is stimulating
and will stimulate a new
species of conversations.
Our intelligence will be
in conversation with itself
in new ways.
And the people who
can do that best
are the innovators, because
you, collectively speaking,
are the dominant influence
in culture right now.
But because your
world view tends
to confine what you think of
as relevant and interesting
to the kinds of things
you already recognize,
you're tending not to recognize
the fresh perspectives
and important truths that are
also being brought forward
by the intelligent
conversations among ecologists
or evolutionaries.
And so it will be the--
not the kind of--
what we might call
the yang heroism,
the very masculine heroism,
kind of like Hercules,
bursting through, of the
innovators saving the day
with new breakthroughs
that will be sufficient,
because the cultural
dimension is going
to require a coming
together of the human family
and of all our intelligence.
So it is innovators,
who by waking up
to a certain fundamental
epistemic humility, recognizing
that the way you know and the
way you see, however clearly
and with whatever profoundly
penetrating laser vision,
you may have, is only
a part of the process
and that you need to
be in conversation
with other perspectives,
and particularly
the families of conversation
that I'm lining out here,
that I call ecologists
and evolutionaries.
So leadership among
innovators, who take seriously
your unique
responsibility, is perhaps
one of the crucial things
that can turn the Titanic.
Many of you are probably
familiar with the idea
of the trim tab.
This is something Bucky
Fuller talked about a lot.
When you have really--
the Queen Mary, a really
large ocean liner, a rudder
turns the ship.
The turning radius
is way too wide.
The efficiency of
navigation is compromised
by the very size of the ship.
Even with massive rudders,
they turn too slow.
But if you put another
little rudder on the end,
not very big, with a
very powerful motor
and all kinds of bracing,
it turns way faster.
That's a trim tab,
that extra rudder.
And if we're going
to turn this Titanic,
it's going to be because
of little acts of heroism
by many, many people
in a broad complex.
It will be necessary for
our best intelligence
not to just rearrange the
deck chairs in this Titanic
metaphor, but to break into the
engine room and grab the wheel
and actually turn the ship.
And I want you to
consider that this
is an inspiring and ennobling
prospect, that it's thrilling
to be alive right now.
In some of the-- you might
say the Jungian and soul based
psychological and
spiritual traditions,
it is said that we consented
to be born in this time.
Whether we think of it
in those terms or not,
we certainly are
born in this time.
This is our time.
Whatever your
character is, it is
going to be expressed in the
peculiar mix of opportunities
and challenges that present
themselves in this time.
And so you have
coincided with a moment
in which the events
in your lifetime
are going to be of
enormous consequence
on an evolutionary
scale, and you
have some measure of
intelligence and capacity
and power.
There's a chilling poem
written by Drew Dellinger,
with lines that go something
like, it's 3:23 in the morning,
and I can't sleep.
I keep hearing the voices of
my great great grandchildren
calling to me,
asking me, what did
you do when the
planet was unraveling?
What did you do when
the oceans were dying?
Once you knew, what did you do?
That's a tremendous
moral seriousness,
and the paradox is
we can't fulfill it
if we let the weight
of that sobriety
kill our sense of humor.
Things are far too serious for
us to lose our sense of humor.
Things are far too serious
for us to lose our capacity
for lightheartedness.
We are being asked to come
into the game with a yes,
we can kind of an attitude, a
can do positive orientation.
And when you begin to
recognize where you really are,
I think instead of arriving in
this orientation of believing
in collapse, which,
in my opinion,
is a problem, because
mindset becomes
a self-fulfilling prophecy.
Things are far
too serious for us
to allow that
pessimism to condition
our way of participating, such
that the potential heroism
that we might bring
to this complex
is dented by our depression,
or our discouragement.
So a whole different quality
of human relationship
is possible and asked
from us right now.
We have to turn to one another.
We've been given a koan, I
can't answer it by myself.
The only answer to
that koan is from us.
It's a collective koan.
And the biggest
problems in our lives
are the same as the biggest
problems in each other's lives.
Whatever the challenges that
you are facing personally,
they're dwarfed by our
collective challenges.
And yet, those
are an opportunity
for a life of meaning and
purpose and contribution.
So that's what I'm
dedicating my life to.
At the end here, we'll put up
a slide with just a few links,
mainly to my work, and also
to this paper I mentioned,
which can serve as a 2
by 4 across the forehead,
the "Deep Adaptation"
paper by Jim Bendell.
It's at lifeworth.com/de
epadaptation.pdf.
My websites are
newrepublicoftheheart.com
about my book,
newrepublicoftheheart.org,
which is the non-profit I've
founded, and terrypatten.com,
and I invite you to
check all of that out.
And I hope you'll read
my book or consider
listening to the audio book.
I've read the audio
book, and so you
can absorb it that way if that's
going to flow in your life
better.
And I hope we have time
for a few questions.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to get your
impression of the cornucopian
myth that we're kind of
fulfilling here at Google,
where there's kind of this--
there's still this impression of
unlimited expansion on the web.
So there's kind of
maybe some impression,
there is maybe a lower
sort of material cost
by servicing equivalent
services or products on the web,
and as a Googler myself,
our targets every quarter
are higher than they
were previously,
our need to fulfill
click volume is
kind of continuing to increase.
I'm just curious
on your perspective
unlike first how the cornucopian
myth has sort of translated
to the digital age.
But also as Googlers, you know,
you said we're innovators.
But are we also not--
do we have a space in trying
to curb some of the expansion,
like in turning the hit
Titanic, to your allusion there,
from where we sit?
TERRY PATTEN: Yeah, I
think that to some degree,
you have to succeed in
the system that you're in,
even if you see that it has
some unhealthy dynamics.
So your participation in doing
your job of helping Google
succeed this quarter
is probably not itself
part of turning the Titanic, no.
But it is--
I don't think it's evil.
I think that it's
part of perpetuating
a system that needs to go
through a more radical change.
And as a participant in
this process, you are--
part of what you can do is--
and I would recommend--
is to grow yourself into--
like most of you Googlers
are relatively young,
and you have a lot of life
and capacity ahead of you,
and so as you cultivate your
consciousness and your capacity
to be a friend to
another person,
and there are a variety of
very ordinary human maturations
that are necessary for you to
be the kind of leader that's
going to be able to be
effective in changing--
the fundamental systems redesign
is probably going to not
be possible until there are
disruptions, positive or
negative.
If somebody comes up with
that cheap free alternative
to fossil fuels, that's going
to be a massive disruption
to the whole economy.
That's going to change a lot.
And you might have
an opportunity
to write the code
for what replaces it.
If there is a massive
ecological disaster that
kills tens of millions
of people and shocks
the world into a whole new
orientation to our place
on the planet, and we've got
countries all over the world,
revising their international
financial agreements,
some people-- perhaps this
isn't your area of expertise,
I suspect.
But we're going to be
rewriting the rules
of our international
financial system.
We're going to be
rewriting the back code.
So your guys' capacity to think
meta systemically and identify
the rule sets that are going
to genuinely be sustainable
is hugely important.
If, for example, in
October or September,
October, November of 2008,
the brightest young thinkers
in financial and economic
theory were giving papers
to Hank Paulson and Ben
Bernanke and George W. Bush that
would have shown them a way of
making good use of that crisis,
they could have nationalized
the banks at that time.
They had lots of
room to really make
fundamental systems redesign.
Those opportunities are
going to come into being.
So using scenario
planning, you can
identify the crises
that are going
to create windows of opportunity
for more fundamental systems
redesign, and you
can be there at
the ready with the white
papers or the thought
through new coding
or rule sets that
are going to make a difference.
And you're the kind of guys
who can think in those terms.
We really do need that
kind of leadership.
And you don't have
to tackle the project
as a current
deliverable that you
have to come up with
this month or this year
in order to begin
to prepare yourself
to be the kind of person
in the kind of position
that can make that
kind of difference.
So that's kind of what
I'm hoping you'll do.
AUDIENCE: It relates
to the question--
it relates to the point about
being epistemically humble
and showing humility from
your particular world view,
and being open to
other world views.
So for example, from the
innovators' perspective
being really opening up to the
perspectives of the ecologists
and the evolutionaries.
Potentially, an
innovator would think
that being open to data, for
example, as is the innovator's
mindset, is kind of an
epistemically humble thing
to do, because you're being
open to the data that's
presented to you.
So to be open to ecologists and
evolutionaries, what would that
look like in practice?
How would you become
more epistemically humble
from your particular
perspective?
TERRY PATTEN: Well,
the main thing
is that you would
have to recognize
that all your data derives from
data collection methods that
are themselves
ways of quantifying
a more complex reality.
And therefore, they're an
incomplete map of that reality.
And so the data
is very powerful,
but it's not omniscient.
And so no matter how voluminous
or good your data is,
it is not a total
picture of reality,
and especially, because we're
facing a critical moment
in which we have to make such
profound whole systems change,
the critical
leadership can't derive
from data that is gathered
in the old pattern.
A new pattern has
to come into being.
And therefore, all that
you can gain from the data
that you have is
incredibly valuable.
But it isn't a total
view of things.
So if you--
I think it's easy
for us to become
inflated by our successes.
And data can help us succeed
famously in the marketplace
and in commerce, and even in
the court of public opinion,
academically, for example.
But it won't.
The design specs for the
challenge that we're all facing
right now are very, very steep.
Our ability to meet those design
specs requires us to get past,
oh I'm doing pretty well.
My income is going up.
Or an attractive person
has come into my life,
and I'm happy about my
relationship in the world.
Those levels of
success are wonderful.
I wish you all the best.
But we've got to crack the code
of how we turn the Titanic.
That's a big, big challenge.
And the existing data will
be of important relevance,
but if we worship
the god of data,
as if it has all the
answers, we're blinkered.
It's just this.
Ken Wilber, my friend
and our co-author
of the book in
real life practice,
uses the term
flatland to describe
the materialist scientific,
objectivist perspective
that tends to dominate
among innovators.
And its biggest
liability is arrogance.
It succeeds in many
ways, but it then
becomes epistemically closed.
It lacks that humility.
So simply taking on board the
fact that you do know a lot,
you can see a lot, the
data shows us a lot,
it's really
valuable, most people
can't understand
it or crunch it,
and I can, and I'm
able to contribute
something that's of real
significance, that's
not enough.
That level of
success-- if you end up
having lived a life in which
you had a successful position
in a corporation that was part
of a pattern that destroyed
the world that your great
grandchildren would have
inherited, your success
is pretty tainted.
So if you bring in the
kind of humility that
cares to really be the change
we want to see in the world,
then your relationship to
the data becomes serious.
And you don't cease to
notice all the opportunities
and possibilities.
But you don't confuse
them with omniscience.
You break below that.
And yes, letting the
data inform your choices
is brilliant and important,
but it's not a panacea.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And with that, we've
come to the end.
So Terry, on behalf
of Google, thank
you so much for sharing your
time and wisdom with us today.
Thank you.